dad
dad dad
dad what georgie keeps kicking me
kick him back i'd rather not touch him
you won't sleep with me yes thank you
enough room yes
you throw off a lot of heat
sorry that's all right
it's kind of nice
they launched those shuttles in the rain
i think a light rain's okay
oh no it'll pass
just get some sleep
it didn't pass
i'm real sorry
i'll tell you a secret never understood
how lightning works
didn't they teach you that in high
school it probably did but
i got hit in the head a lot playing
football
would you explain it to me well when
positive and negative charges grow large
enough a giant spark occurs in the cloud
that's that's pretty cool
what causes the thunder it's a shock
wave from particles heated to 10
000 degrees interesting
you want to know what's really
interesting aristotle thought
the sound of thunder was due to a
collision between two clouds
he believed the clouds were expelling
her in the way a log on fire crackles
i didn't realize until years later that
my father was only asking questions
about lightning and thunder
to cheer me up in fact he would often
pretend to be dumb just to make me feel
better
looks like rain my brother on the other
hand didn't have to pretend
all right here we go ready one two three
buddy thought we had a plan you had a
plan
[Music]
i never did get to see a launch in
person but that was the best trip i ever
had
[Music]
i wish i had told my father while he was
alive
[Music]
[Applause]
bye
the